hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the sanatorium now this
is another game that has been suggested
a lot by you guys so I thought I'd give
it a try
yes sanatorium the gameplay mechanics
from what I read in the readme file are
basically the same as yeah
the objective is similar collect 8 pages
but in a different environment so I'm
actually playing this one at exactly
midnight tonight so says dark as I could
possibly make it in my room so let's see
basically I get that this is either a
mental hospital or an old-style nurse
mental hospital
Arnold something closet hiding you
probably not I doubt that hiding would
do anything I've never seen anything
about this I don't know I get the idea
um the more you sprint the faster or the
less you're able to sprint in the long
run I don't know man you go slow very
slow I don't believe that this game is
made in a Unity engine so it's something
else but still looks rather nice guys
computer lab aha yeah my first page out
of sight not Adam oh that's familiar I
remember that
I'm okay nothing bad whoa
seriously haha that match huh I never
mind I thought that this is a bunch of
bars I thought they were like tentacles
coming out of slender man's back
oh okay sorry
oh I didn't notice you were on bed there
doing something uh I'll go away um not
to there oh haha oh no that's the same
room oh boy uh okay all right gotta get
all the pages go get all the page good
witness winders mm-hmm
the last time I played the other slender
game I think I got up to six pages so
I'm gonna really gonna try to break that
man I'm totally gonna get turned around
because all of this looks the same like
everything looks exactly the same
I'm going here
so I know I'm probably just gonna wind
up going in circles I mean part of the
reason that you're able to get the page
as quickly as if you already know you
know the layout and where they typically
spawn I could go that way I got a bad
feeling about that way all right
oh man why was he on that bed why was he
just uh it's okay though I'm sorry okay
it's fine it's all good here no big deal
NBD oh hello
stares into your soul hahaha I have no
soul
Oh joke's on you slender man 2 of 8 they
can bacon Oh dad him out him I saw him I
saw him I'm not gonna uh I'm not gonna
be the mistake of turning around so much
in this plan who was that said our lion
because turning around is bad for my
health
hmm okay I just turned around uh-huh
what is a lion for another page could
spawn with our thoughts we create the
world indubitably mr. Lyon important
thought for Lyon that moving forward
ah oh yeah
took my girl now coming for me oh [ __ ]
girl
Oh how's him stay back get back
nobody likes you nobody likes you okay
oh that's a new sound I'm gonna circle
orna oh I feel like I'm gonna circle
bathroom oh oh I'm on a roll
oh yeah it came from the forest no okay
this is going slightly circle slight
circle ha wait I went through here let
me go back here
what was that what is Evan
oh why why why did he get me why I just
suddenly suddenly I started like jerking
to the left and right and then I'll send
bone he was all up in my grill let's try
it again I thought I don't know why I
don't know why you got me anyway
dick - I generally based on slender so I
get it this sounds like some persons
running in from the forest like this guy
was saying that he didn't mean to copy
ah the other guy he just wanted to make
an extension of the game that goes into
another area which is kind of cool
I mean it's building off of an indie
title I mean I hope he worked together
with the guy anyway
so anyway I don't know exactly what
happened there I thought I was doing
fine Olsen but then all the sudden
Slenderman was right there and I died or
something like that I don't know either
way
Kenneth sucked but oh well I mean what
you gonna do
oh hello
always watching
boom right onto the first page for a big
displaces I'm finding these pages
relatively easily cotton I'm gonna go
this way make a loop again see if I can
get to where I need to be I was just my
first spotted Slendy I think it was I
think this is the room where I first
spotted him so let's go around okay oh
man I get goosebumps from when he got me
there just all the sudden out of nowhere
Slenderman decide hey buddy how you
doing how you doing collecting those
pages uh-oh uh-oh nowhere to run nowhere
to hide
oh he was in that room
he likes that room that's the same room
not that I can run anyway well I mean I
tell him then oh [ __ ] that is him oh
sorry how's this like staring at him my
bad yeah I mean I can run but you know
running reduces salmon maybe he was like
oh maybe he was creeping up behind me
and I wasn't running fast enough maybe I
should check behind me more often just
to see if he's there cuz if I know he's
there then I'll know to run or that's
the theory anyway probably bad theory
I'm full of bad ideas just like playing
this game there no I am brave brave them
rig Oh big boy I'm a big man ma I'm a
man I can play scary games whoa ha ha ha
wah aah
there's a line there picture or is there
a page on the lion I know that one of
you linked me to a comic that had Slendy
child drew pictures of his dad and but
there's no excuse for that in this game
because they're not pictures they're
creepiness they're letters of greep
I think it's on another page somewhere
around here I know it's probably
randomly distributed aah
took my girl pearl that's the same one
in the same place up he's right there
all right where was an egg I went
through the bathroom here I think this
is and I was able to find another okay
so maybe it's or maybe they're just only
certain spots uh oh yeah came from the
forest okay 4 of 8 4 of 8 doing good
doing good
okay Bay it up and I know as I went
farther down here it's probably because
I backtrack in a circle I probably ran
right into him so it's the most
important lesson is just to keep moving
forward in a direction progress
I think in here no aw crap um I'm afraid
to get trapped in the room with them
okay
we're doing good though we're doing good
nope if I miss a page just oh wait I'm
back at the beginning
whatever it is if I miss page just yell
it yell at your screen shake your fist
semi just say no [ __ ]
oh dude okay ah
five five five no one survived I must
survive what happened no no no no no no
no no no no no no I remember that one
page well haha I'm running I'm running
okay gimme running okay I'm winded I'm a
guy now no stop that I don't remember
where I got the other pages I can't
remember where I was I got them but I
went came up that let me go down here
into that room okay I got this I got
this I guess I got this I got I got it I
got it
I got it I got it I got it like that at
all
I haven't seen slander urge a no don't
tell me works but I'd rather keep my eye
on him that I know he's not gonna just
be creeping up on me
okay all this is way back it's way back
where I was
okay I'm getting close to cycling back I
must I must have I missed a hallway
where I need to check some rooms because
oh yeah the computer lab was it this for
yes
oh yeah six of eight oh yeah side not
out of mind okay that's okay that's okay
I'm okay with that where is Lee ah there
is okay he's okay I don't need to run
I'm pretty far away okay so um okay that
goes I think that's the bathroom over
there actually that um I came up on the
right side of the building
I've already gone that one have I I
don't know better check it anyway just
make sure okay yeah I've already gone
these and I went left what I know I
didn't but this is the entrance oh where
am I okay I went right there we were
left here two rooms here
why I was looking at him ah I wasn't I
didn't I didn't I didn't look at him I
didn't look at him okay
all right oh man I'm gonna take a break
from that I got six of eight matched my
old record in the first game huh okay
anyway oh man I might pick this up again
at another time I own I know I only did
the first one once but uh that was
intense
ooh boy all right so anyway I might pick
this up again let me know if you want me
to do it again and I might subject
myself to the terror that is slender I
mean honestly the first one I don't
think got me that like like affected me
that much for some reason maybe it was
because it was more open but with that
game it was like you could check around
a corner and all of a sudden she'd be
there so that was very worrisome but
anyway alright thank you guys so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye